[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام وكل عام وانتم
بالف خير لماذا بات الكثير من العرب
يطبلوا ويزمر لظهور نظام دولي جديد متعدد
الاقطاب لماذا يرون في روسيا والصين منقذا
من امريكا اليست هذه نظره صبيانيه متخلفه
ماذا يحمل الروس والصينيون للعالم اصلع
اما زالوا مجرد عزقات في النظام الامريكي
ماذا استفاد العرب من النظام الدولي
القديم ايام الاتحاد السوفيتي اما زالت
الدول العربيه التي كانت تدور في الفلك
السوفيتي رمزا للتخلف والانهيار كسوريا
والعراق واليمن والجزائر والسودان
فكيف يكررون الخطا بالمراهنه على روسيا
والصين اليوم
لكن في المقابل الم تبدا ملامح النظام
الدولي الجديد بالظهور بعد دخول الصين على
خط المنافسه مع امريكا في الخليج
اليس من حق العرب ان يوازنوا تحالفاتهم
بين الشرق والغرب كي لا يبقوا مجرد توابع
للهيمنه الامريكيه الا يمكن ان يستفيدوا
كثيرا من الصراع الدولي بين امريكا وروسيا
والصين الا يشكل لقاء العملاقين الصينيه
والروسيه في موسكو قبل ايام نقطه تحول
كبرى في التحولات الدوليه وعلى العرب
اقتناصه الفرص لتوزيع او تنويع تحالفاتهم
في اكثر من اتجاه اسئله اطرحه عبر الاقمار
الصناعيه من بيروت على الخبير
الاستراتيجيه الدكتور رياض عيد
ومن واشنطن على مجد خليل الخبير في الشؤون
الدوليه نبدا نقاش بعد الفاصل
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام نحن
معكم في برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس دكتور
رياض لو بدات معك من بيروت هل نحن فعلا
على ابواب نظام دولي جديد وان العرب الذين
بداوا ينوعون تحالفاتهم بين الشرق والغرب
فعلا على صواب
تحيه لك
ولضيفك الكريم الدكتور مجدي
ويعني رمضان مبارك لك ولكل المشاهدين
الكرام
اولا يعني نعم نحن على ابواب نظام عالمي
جديد يعني بدا هذا النظام الاحاديث القطبي
يتداعى من سوريا الى افغانستان والان انا
اعتقد ان هذا النظام قد دفن في اوكرانيا
والمعركه التي تدار في اوكرانيا هي معركه
ما بين روسيا الاتحاديه من ناحيه والغرب
الانجلوس برمته تخاط في كل الشؤون تخاف في
الشق العسكري في اوكرانيا وتخاط في شق
الطاقوي مع اوروبا والاطلسي وتخاط ايضا
بموضوع الغذاء العالمي لحجم وتاثير روسيا
في هذه الملفات كل هذه الامور تؤكد على ان
النظام الاحادي القطب قد انتهى والتسجيل
الامريكيين يعت ان نظام الاحاديث القطبيه
قد انتهى وعميرك عليها ان تعترف بهذه
القوه الناهضه من الشرق التي تزاحم امريكا
على عرش الكون اقتصاديا وجيو استراتيجيا
انطلاقا من هذه الرؤى وخاصه بعد التراجعات
الكبيره التي حدثت لامريكا اقتصاديا بعد
جائحه كورونا وبعد يعني التعثر الكبير
الذي حدث في اقتصاديات امريكا واوروبا بعد
الحرب الاوكرانيه وبعد ازمه البنوك
سيليكون فالي
وكريدي سويس في سويسرا كل هذه الامور جعلت
العربي يتاكدوا ان وضع الغرب
الانجلوساكسوني برمته هو وضع غير سليم
اقتصاديا وهو غير قادر ان يستمر في حكم
الكون وهو متعثر في حربه مع روسيا
وبالتالي من حق الدول العربيه ان تحتاط
وتنوع علاقاتها خاصه ان العلاقه العربيه
مع امريكا كانت مصلحه من جانب واحد مولت
الدول العربيه كل حروب في المنطقه استغلت
امريكا كل الدول العربيه وناهبت بترول
العالم العربي ودمرت الدول العربيه
باحتلالاتها للعراق وشمال سوريا وزرعت
الكيان الاسرائيلي في في جنوب جنوب فلسطين
كل هذه المعطيات ان اكدت تؤكد ان امريكا
والغرب الاستعماري لا يريد من منطقتنا الا
استنزافها بالمقابل هناك قوه صاعده صينيه
روسيه قوه اوراسيا العملاقين في اوراسيا
هذان العملاقان يريدون من المنطقه ان
تقيموا شركات استراتيجيه معها لتامين
المصالح المشتركه ويريد ان ينهو الصراعات
في المنطقه لان امريكا واسرائيل والغرب
الاستعماري استغل الصراع السن الشيعي فاتت
الصين تقدم نموذجا جديدا ينهي نافذه
المذهبيه والصراع المذهب الذي دمر المنطقه
وتقول انا جاهزه ان استثمر في المنطقه كي
تتحول المنطقه الى واحه من الاستثمار
العالمي لذلك راينا هذا الانزياح العربي
باتجاه الشرق مع الابقاء على علاقاتهم مع
الغرب وهذا ان دل على يدل على يقضى عربيه
جديده جدا من مصالحهم الوطنيه والاقتصاديه
حلو جدا مجدي خليل هل تستطيع ان ترد على
ريان محق جميل جدا هل تستطيع ان ترد على
ذلك مجدي خليل
اولا مساء الخير لك ولضيفك وللمشاهدين
الكرام حول العالم دعني اوضح للموضوع اكثر
فيما يتعلق بالنظام الدولي منذ اكثر من
عشرين عاما وانا بسمع النظام الدوله
هينهار النظام الدولي اتعمل يعني ده مش
جديد ارجع لمقالات من عشرين سنه هتلاقي
نفس الكلام ولكن انا اقدر اارخ لبدايه
الهجوم على النظام الدولي في 5 فبراير
2022 عندما اجتمع
وقالوا شراكه بلا حدود وقالوا اسقاط هيمنه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على النظام
الدولي هذه هي فتره التاريخ بعدها باسابيع
غزا
بوتين اوكرانيا وهم بيقدموا حاجتين لان
هذا النظام الدولي بيقدموا الهيمنه
والامبرياليه عوده الامبرياليه والهيمنه
هذا ما يقدمه الصين وروسيا بعد كده في
يونيو 2022 اجتمع حلف شمال الاطلسي
ومجموعه سبعه وفعلا اقروا ان روسيا والصين
خلي بالك قالوا الصين الصين وروسيا يمثلان
تهديدا للنظام الدولي القائم على القواعد
هنا نبدا نقول ان بدايه الهجوم على النظام
الدولي القائم على سياده الدول والقائم
على القواعد والقائم على القانون الدولي
والقائم على مواثيق حقوق الانسان الدولي
والامم المتحده كل ذلك حدث في انا بارخ له
من خمسه فبراير الفين 2022 واخر زياره اخر
زياره لشيء الى الى روسيا قال له ان احنا
بنعمل تغييرات ما حصلتش من 100 سنه بيكلم
بوتين وانا وانت بنعمل تغييرات ما حصلتش
من 100 سنه يعني من ايام عصبه الامم
المتحده من ايام الحرب العالميه الثانيه
يعني هم بيقولوا نحن نعمل على هدم النظام
الدولي خلي بالك اولا اولا يبقى احنا
بدانا فين في فتره هدم النظام الدولي
النظام الدولي ما زال قائمه ولكن ضعيف
وفعاليته قليله يبقى هجم الدولي ده هياخد
له الى 10 من عشره الى عشرين سنه الناس
بتتصور ان نظام دولي معقد ومركب بهذه
الحجم هيتهدم في خلال 24 ساعه النظام
الدولي سياخذ 10 الى 20 سنه وبعدها على
الاقل 10 سنين عشان يتشكل ملامح نظام جديد
اذا كان هناك ملامح نظام جديد هم لم
يقدموا ملامح نظام جديد سوى الامبرياليه
والهيمنه في كل هذه الفتره سيتحدث فوضى
وحروب وصدامات وسرعات سياسيه واقتصاديه
وسيكون الشرق الاوسط كالمعتاد مسرحا لهذه
الصراعات وبعد ذلك بعد ذلك سيكون الشرق
الاوسط توابع للفائز سيرجع توابع للشاه
يعني احنا عندما يتكلمون في الشرق الاوسط
وبيتصوروا هم في الشرق الاوسط عندهم
اعجاب بالمستبدين الاقوياء بوتين وشيء
عندهم انبهار بالمستبدين الاقوياء بوتين
وشيء هذا كل المساله المساله ان عندما
يتحدثون في الشرق الاوسط يقولون ايه الشرق
الاوسط مهم للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الشرق الاوسط مهمه لروسيا الشرق الاوسط
مهمه للصين معناها انهم مفعول بهم وليسوا
فاعلين معناههم انه ليس كتله فاعله لا
يوجد شيء اسمه كيان عربي اللي بيتكلم
الدول العربيه في دول الخليج نفسها لا
يمكن ان تجد دولتين اللي هم الاكثر
انسجاما لا يمكن ان تجد دولتين في دول
الخليج نفسهم متفقين على قضيه واحده فكيف
تقول عرب عرب ايه وفين العرب اللي
بيتكلموا عليهم دول العرب ايام عبد الناصر
اراهنوا على الاتحاد السوفيتي اللي هي
بنقول عليهم يوليا واخواتها السبعه شوفهم
دلوقتي السودان وليبيا ومنظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه والجزائر ومصر واليمن وسوريا
والعراق فين الدول دي حاليا فين هذه الدول
مزيد من الفساد والاستبداد والتطرف وكل
شيء هذا هذه
والانهيار على فكره عاوز اقول لك حاجه على
فكره ايه مشكله اوكرانيا ومشكله تايوان
مشكله اوكرانيا وتايوان انهم منبهرين
بنظام الديمقراطيه والنظام الليبرالي
والراسماليه خطر اوكرانيا على على بوتين
انه خايف احسن تكتسح هذه الافكار روسيا
نفسها هو خايف من الديمقراطيه وشيء خايف
من الديمقراطيه بعد ان صدر ديمقراطيه في
بلده وبعد ان صادر بوتين الديمقراطيه
وازلوا المعارضه هم خايفين من هذه النماذج
ماذا قدمت الصين هل قدمت
السريلانكا المنهاره ولا ميانمار ولا
كوريا الشماليه ولا كوبا ولا فنزويلا ايه
النماذج اللي قدموها الشرق الاوسط دول
الخليج هي الدول الوحيده
المزدهره في الشرق الاوسط هل تعلم لماذا
دول الخليج منبهره في الشرق الاوسط دول
الخليج مباره في الشرق الاوسط لانها بنتها
بناها امريكا والغرب في خلال سنه الاخيره
بالكامل اذا كانوا براهنوا على المستبدين
وكما يقول
ان بن سلمان الامير بن سلمان بيلعب لعبه
عبد الناصر اللي كان بيلعب ما بين الاتحاد
السوفيتي وما بين امريكا بس قال له انتبه
ان عبد الناصر لم ينتصر في النهايه عبد
الناصر فشل ونموزه فشله والدول التي دارت
في فلكه فشلك لا تراهن على دول لا تراهن
على الاستبداد لا تراهن على على الهيمنه
والامبرياليه الصين تقدم نموذج الهيمنه
الاقليميه يعني سيب كل واحد يهيمن في
المنطقه بتاعته لا يقال ايه اللي تقدمه
للنموذج الدولي ماذا تقدم صين الصين
النموذجيه الدولي عندما ويلسون في عصبه
الامم قدم مبادئها ال 14 ومنها حق كل شعب
في تقرير مصيره ثم روسفيلد قد من اربع
حاجات التحرر من العوز والخوف
والاستبداد كله والديمقراطيه قدموا
الديمقراطيه قدموا حقوق الانسان قدم حقوق
الانسان الدوليه قدموا الامم المتحده
قدموا الاقتصاد الدولي قدموا المؤسسات
الدوليه قدموا البنوك الدوليه هو يقدم
طريق الحرير طريق الحرير هو طريق استعماري
جديد ماذا انت لو شفت
الصين عندها مبدا خطير التمويل الاستحوازي
وهذا هو طريق طريق الحرير هو
هو طريق استعماري اقتصادي جديد اذا لم
تدفع فنحصل على تحوز على على ممتلك
مجلي وصلت فكره ممتاز دكتور رياض طيب انا
اسالك دكتور رياض ما الذي يجعلك متحمسا
لهذا
الانفلاج الصيني
الروسي في العالم دكتور رياض انت تعلم ان
ابعد قاعده عسكريه امريكيه عن الصين 45
كيلو فقط يعني محاصره الصين كل التحالفات
التي اجرتها امريكا في الفتره الاخيره من
بينها وبين بريطانيا
واستراليا الى الاكواد بيننا وبين
استراليا والهند واليابان الى الى الى يا
رجل انت تتحدث عن صين عن صين محاصره عن
روسيا محاصره روسيا تقول لك انا الغرب
يحاصرني وانا في الزاويه والصين هي في
الزاويه دلني على طريق ياخذ النفط او
الطاقه الى الصين الا وتحاصروا امريكا
والغرب صين ايه وما بعرف شو يعني ونفس
الشيء في الصين الصين محاصره هؤلاء عباره
عن عزقات عزقات في النظام الامريكي فما
تروحوا بعيد كثير كيف ترد
اولا يعني انا اريد اذا بتسمح لي قبل ما
ارد على هاي اذا بتسمح بس اضطرق لما ذكروا
الدكتور مجدي اولا يا دكتور مجدي روسيا لا
تهاجم امريكا في حدائقها والصين لا تهاجم
امريكا في حدائقها الخلفيه امريكا هي التي
تمددت في حلف
الفارسوبيا في حلف وارسو وباتت 18 دوله من
حلف وارسو بعد علما ان هناك اتفاق روسي
امريكي بان لا تتمدد امريكي في المنطقه
منذ ايام تكلم جرام فولتم ان الصراع هو
صراع وفق نظريه
على الراين لاند وعلى امريكا ان تمنع
روسيا تسيطر على الريم لاند اذا في صراع
جيب بوليتيكي مع روسيا على هذه المنطقه
لدفع روسيا من الداخل الخرب في اوكرانيا
اتت لاستنزاف روسيا بغرض افشال روسيا
واسقاطها من الداخل لكن الرئيس بوتين كان
متحضر للعبه الامريكيه وبدل ان تستنظف
السياره راينا الاستنزافات قائمه في
اوروبا وامريكا اذا اين روسيا موجوده في
في حدائق امريكا الخلفيه هي غير موجوده
بالنسبه للصين ايضا هل يعني انا اريد ان
اسالك ماذا يعني تزويد استراليا بغواصات
امريكيه وبريطانيه تعمل بالطاقه الذريه في
نووي نعم ماذا يعني تخلي اليابان مؤخرا عن
دستورها السلمي واعلان عن زياده موازنتها
العسكريه كي تتصدى للصين في جزر سانكاكو
وظهر الصين يعني ماذا تعني العقيده
العسكريه الجديده لحلف الاطلس التي تعتبر
ان الصين هو العدو الاول
والمزاحم لها وعليها ان تتصدى له ماذا
يعني القواعد الامريكيه جديده في الفلبين
والحصول على تسهيلات من اندونيسيا
وماليزيا وفيتنام ماذا يعني يا صديقي
العزيز ان قبل ايام سحبت امريكا طائراتها
المقاتله الشرق الاوسط وارسلتهم الى بحر
الصين والى روسيا والى اوروبا كانت تقاتل
فيها الصين وروسيا كل هذه الامور تؤكد ان
ليس الصين وروسيا هي قوه استعماريه بل
امريكا هي القوه الاستعماريه التي تقاتل
في حدائق روسيا الخلفيه وتقاتل في بحر
الصين الذي هو تعتبره الصين هو مياه
الاقليميه من هنا انا اعتبر تسمح لي عليك
ان تحدث معلوماتك في هذا الشان لان الصين
وروسيا تقاتل من موقع الدفاع عن النفس
لاقامه نظام عالمي جديد اكثر عداله واكثر
فعلا ازدهارا للبشريه امريكا
والصين تبحثان عن عالم او تعملان من اجل
عالم او نظام دولي اكثر عداله يا دكتور
رياض
عندما نهاجم الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا فهذا
لا يعني اننا نتجاهل الغزو الامريكي
الهمجي للعراق وافغانستان والصومال وسوريا
بل نحن نطالب فقط بان يكون هناك نظام دولي
جديد يمنع كل انواع الغزو
لكن المصحح لكن المضحك لكن المضحك ان
النظام الدولي الجديد الذي يطبل ويزمر له
البعض والذي تدعو اليه انت وروسيا والصين
بدا بغزو اوكرانيا يعني شهاب الدين من
اخيه اسوا من اخيه مشان ما نحط الكلمه
الثاني المعروف فيه كيف ترد ما مشكله اولا
يعني من تكلم السيمر هيرش ان هناك كان
معلومات
والامريكيين يريدوا ان يهاجموا روسيا من
اوكرانيا كي يستعيدوا القرم يعني الحرب
التي اقامتها روسيا ضد اوكرانيا هي حرب
استباقيه لان المخابرات الروسيه كانت تؤكد
ان الحلف الاطلسي يهيئ اوكرانيا كي يقيموا
الحرب على روسيا وحين انقلب نظام الحكم في
اوكرانيا كانت فيكتوريا نولاند هي مساعده
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه للشؤون الاوروبيه
قالت نحن وضعنا صرفنا خمسه مليار دولار
لتحريك الثوره البرتقاليه كي نمنع هيمنه
روسيا او العلاقه بين روسيا واوكرانيا لان
وفق نظريه بروجنسكي اذا اردت ان تمنع
روسيا من ان تكون دوله قاره امبراطوريه
عليك ان تحرمها من اوكرانيا ومن حدائقها
الخلفيه في الراي لاند اذا روسيا قتلت
معركه استباقيه تقول لي كيف تريد ان تقيم
نظام العداله ما لم يكسر هذا الغرب
الاستعماري ما لم يهزم في عقر داره لا
تستطيع ان تبني نظام جديد امريكا لا تزال
متعنت الان لا تزال متعنطه في حرب هذا
الروسيا ولا تزال تدفع باوكرانيا وتدفع
بالماء
والسلاح
كي تفك المشكله انتو عم تحكوا عن اوكرانيا
كما لو انه امريكا اللي غازته اوكرانيا
كما لو انه بريطانيا اللي غزت اوكرانيا يا
رجل نحن ليش اوكرانيا الذي غزا اوكرانيا
هي روسيا فليش انتو عم والله امريكا كذا
وامريكا بدها كذا يا اخي الروح اللي غزا
خليني برجع بس خليني اسال مجدي خليني اسال
مجدي مجدي مجدي العرب
اشتباقيه ماشي العرب مجدي العرب العرب
الان عندما يتوجهون شرقا عندما يبداون
بتنويع تحالفاتهم بين هذه القوه الصاعده
هم مجبرون على ذلك كل الذين يذهبون باتجاه
الصين وباتجاه روسيا لان امريكا خذلتهم
ماذا قدمت لنا امريكا لماذا قدمت لنا
امريكا قدمت لنا الغزو الذي دمر العراق
الغزو الذي تحتل شرق سوريا امريكا التي
غزت الصومال امريكا التي تعين كل الطواغيت
والجنرالات الذين يدوسون علينا في هذه
المنطقه ماذا نريد من امريكا يا مجدي يا
مجدي تتحدث لي عن حقوق انسان وديمقراطيه
يا مجدي حقوق انسان وديمقراطيه دلني دلني
على جنرال عربي دلني على جنرال عربي تعرف
ترامب هذا يوم شاف احد احد الطواغيت قال
له يو ار مايك يا رجل كل الطغاه العرب
الذين يدوسون علينا الان هم صناعه امريكيه
بالمناسبه حتى بشار الاسد ليس صناعه روسيه
بوتين قال انا ما الي علاقه فيه اصلا هذا
واحد غربي هذا واحد امريكي اذا شو هو
بالعكس تماما خلينا نجرب الصيني خلينا
نجرب الروسي هو اصلا امريكا لم تصدر لنا
الا الطاغوت والقتل والاجرام وكل شيء كيف
ترد
ارد عليك يعني انا بعتبر اكبر خطا
استراتيجي عملته الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هو غزو العراق ماشي لان هو كان
ضد نظام ضد القانون الدولي ولكن المؤسف ان
العرب كلهم ايدوا غزو العراق وحمت بن جاسم
كان كان في لقاء قريبا قال كل العرب بما
فيهم السعوديه ايدوا غزو العراق يعني
المشكله الخطا الاستراتيجي الاكبر اللي
عملته امريكا العرب كلهم صحيح هذا الكلام
صحيح
على امريكا وخاصه في دول الخليج اولا
لانهم تخلت لان الربيع العربي امريكا لم
تصنع الربيع العربي ولكن ايده الشباب اللي
كان موجود في الشوارع تاييد الشباب ضد
الديكتاتوريين هو الذي غير العرب 180 درجه
عاوزينها تحمل مستبدين حتى ضد شعبهم هي هي
لم تقاوم المستبدين
لهذا ذهبوا الى بوتين كي يحميهم كي يحموهم
صحيح
الحاجه التانيه اللي واخدينها على امريكا
انما حربتلهمش ولايه الفقيه فئران يعني
عاوزينها امريكا تحارب حروبهم كما حدث سنه
91 وان تترك وان تساند تدخل بقواتها
لمسانده المستبدين يعني هي ما عملتش
الربيع العربي هو طالع من من من قلب
الشباب من احتياجات المنطقه من التشوق الى
الديمقراطيه ولكن خطا امريكا في وجهه
نظرهم انها ثابت الشباب دي انهم ياخدوا
ياخدوا الحكم ده اول حاجه بالتالي هم ما
بيدوروش على شيء يتعلق بامريكا ذو قيمه هم
ايدوها في غزو العراق نرجع الى ما قاله
ضيفك
حتى مجدي خليل حتى القومجيه حتى النظام
القوميجي السوري اه ارسل قوات لتذبح
العراقيين لتقاتل الى جانب الامريكينا ضد
العراق حتى بشار الاسد حتى القومشيه هذول
الطربجيه بما فيها ايران كل الدول العربيه
ايدت تاييد رس في سوريا وايران يعني عشان
نكون واضحين ايدوا غزو العراق نعم نيجي
النقطه التانيه بيتكلم عن الصين الصين
الذي تعلن انها
ستهد النظام الدولي هتهد النظام الدولي
النظام الدولي ده هو قائم بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه اللي قام به الغرب
الحضاره الغربيه العظيمه التي لا توجد
حضاره زيها في تاريخ الانسانيه اللي كل
منتجات العالم كله منها كل شيء في العالم
منها والصين ليست اكثر من سارق
للتكنولوجيا سارق للتكنولوجيا وبالتالي
عاوز يهد الحضاره بيقول سنه 2049 بمئويه
الصين بمئويه تاسيس الشيوعيه في الصين
سينتهي قرن الاذلال الصيني وهو شيء بيقول
ان انا ساحل محل امريكا والغرب والغرب
يعني عاوز يهد الغرب كله والحضاره الغربيه
هيقدم ماشي ماذا يقدم شيء يقدم شيطنه
الديمقراطيه وجاذبيه الاستبداد في حاجه
اسمها جاذبيه الاستبداد بالذمتك في حاجه
اسمها جاذبيه الاستبداد بيقدم
الثقه في الديكتاتوريات بيقول الثقه في
الديكتاتوريات يعني هل هل هذا ايضا شيء له
قيمه الثقه في الديكتاتوريه طبعا له قيمه
عند الطواغيت العرب عند الطغاه العرب من
المحيط الى الخليج
الاستعمار الاقتصادي الجديد الهيمنه
الاقليميه
التمويل الاستحوازي هذا ما تقدمه الصين
الصين بدات اللي بيتكلم ويقول ان راحوا
القوس وكواد وكلام الصين بدات في عسكره
بحر الصين اللي هو بتمر فيه 40% من تجاره
العالم وعملت جزر صناعيه لم تعترف
بالقانون الدولي ولا باحكام محكمه العدل
الدوليه
وجيرانها كل جيران الصير ينصرون منها ولا
يرونها نموذجا اذا ولا جاره من الجيران
الصين بتقول ان السن نموذج يصلح للتقليد
وقالت سنهد النظام الدولي وسننشر الفوضى
وسنسقط الغرب وسنسقط امريكا
واسرع تسليح في العالم هو في الصين تخطط
لبناء 1500 قنبله نوويه في 20 سنه القادمه
لسه حاصله على 25 طن من اليورانيوم من من
روسيا تستخدم روسيا
لهدم النظام الدولي ثم شيء يريد ان يكون
هو الفائز الوحيد من غزوه انا استغرب
باختصار بجمله واحده باختصار
غزو اكبر دوله في اوروبا يؤيدوه العرب
والقومجيه وهذا سقوط اخلاقي قبل ان يكون
سقوط سياسي وسقوط القانون جميل جدا
ذلك مجدي قلنا من المضحك من المضحك ان
بوتين يريد ان يبني نظاما دوليا جديدا
قائما على الغزو اول شغله اخونا بالليل
عملها راح غزه اوكرانيا طيب دكتور رياض
انا بدي اسالك قبل قليل قلت انه يعني
الصين وروسيا ليستا يعني مثلا
دولتين
استعماريتين ولا عندهم نوايا عدوانيه ولا
ولا دكتور رياض يعني نحن ليش النقع بنفس
الجوره بدي اسالك سؤال الاتحاد السوفيتي
اللي وضع الكثير من العرب بيضهم فيه او في
سلته ماذا كان الاتحاد السوفيتي هل كان
الاتحاد السوفيتي يعني نظام افلاطون او
جمهوريه افلاطون ام كان مبنيا على الغزو
كان مبنيا على الاستعمار كان مبنيا على
الارهاب كان مبنيا على الاضطهاد الاتحاد
السوفيتي فرض نفسه على خمسين دوله احتل 50
دوله كل الدول التي كانت تحت الاتحاد
السوفيتي تركته وخرجت لو كانت لو لم تكن
تحت الاحتلال لما تركت الاتحاد السوفيتي
وانت تعلم دكتور رياض
1906/1968 ربيع براق عندما حاول دوب تشيك
ان يخرج من الاتحاد السوفيتي خلال خمس
دقائق كانت الدبابات السوفيتيه في شوارع
براك في شوارع وقال يومها وقال يومها
بامكانكم ان تسحقوا الازه ار لكن ليس
بامكانكم ان توقفوا الربيع فنحن على من
نراهن على الاتحاد السوفيتي اللي كان
مستعمر خمسين دوله اللي كان يبعت دباباته
لكل واحد يرفع راسه شوي يعني ليش منرجع
منعيد نفس المشكله دكتور رياض
نحن لا نراهن على الاتحاد السوفيتي
الاتحاد السوفيتي انتهى كان هناك محطات
مظلمه في الاتحاد السوفيتي لكن ايضا
بالنسبه لنا كعلم عربي نحن قتلنا دوله
العدو الاسرائيلي بسلاح سوفيتي وحين كانت
روسيا الاتحاد السوفياتي عفوا موجود كان
هناك ثنائيه قطبيه في العالم هذه الثنائيه
القطبيه فرضت استقرار معين مقبول الى حد
ما ومنعت الهيمنه الامريكيه بينما الان
هذا النظام العالمي الذي الاحاديث القطب
الذي يتكلم عنه الاستاذ مجدي بانه يعني
اتى بعد الحرب البارده ليس صحيح هذا
النظام الاحادي القطب اتى بعد انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي وبعد ان قرر المحافظين
الجدد في امريكا ان تكون امريكا هي القاره
للقرن ال 21
وبالتالي هي تريد ان تضرب اي قوه ممكن ان
تقوم استباقيا وتنفسها في المستقبل اذا
نحن في نظام ليس هو امتداد للنظام بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه هذا النظام بدا
بعد انهيار الاتحاد السوفياتي
الخبير والمتابع لخطابات بوتين بوتين له
جمله شهيره قال من اكبر الكوارث التي حدثت
للشعب الروسي على على مدى التاريخ انهيار
طيب اذا هو الزلمه يريد ان يحيى
الحركاته الغزو الغزو واوكرانيا اذا تسمح
لي شو اسمه عفوا كل الجمهوريات السابقه
كازاخستان وروسيا البيضاء الان يرسل
صواريخه النوويه الى روسيا البيضاء هو
يريد الاتحاد السوفيتي من جديد لكن بعقليه
ابشع بالف مره اين ذاهبون انتم ايها
العربان يتساءل البعض كيف ترد
اولا الاتحاد روسيا الاتحاديه الان اطلاقا
ليست هي الاتحاد السوفيتي اطلاقا روسيا
الان تعتبر وانا اعتبر هكذا ان الصراع
الكوني تحكمه جغرافيا السياسيه والاقتصاد
اذا نحن لا نستطيع ان نعتبر ان التدخل في
الحدائق الخلفيه التي تمثل امن قومي للدول
لا نستطيع ان نعتبره هذا مساله عارضه قبل
ان تبدا الحرب في اوكرانيا اجتمع الرئيس
بوتين مع الاتحاد الاوروبي مع
الحلف الاطلس هو مع امريكا طرح ثلاث شروط
او ثلاث طلبات الطلب الاول ان لا تدخل
اوكرانيا في الحلف الاطلسي لان هذا يجعل
صواريخ الاحلف الاطلسي قريبه من موسكو مما
يهدد الامن القومي الروسي وقال للاوروبيين
الامن في اوروبا هو امن مشترك بين روسيا
واوروبا تعالوا نتفق امن متوازن ياخذ بعين
الاعتبار مصالح الجميع
واجتمع ايضا ب 12 باطل الماضي سنه الماضي
مع الامريكيين وقال لهم النظام العالمي
الذي ارسل بعدها انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي
هذا النظام لم يحقق انتهاء الحروب وحل
النزاعات بل اجهزها النزاعات نتيجه حرب
امريكا الاشتباقيه تعالوا نفتش عن نظام
عالمي جديد يبنى على اساس احترام القانون
الدولي ومنع التدخل في شؤون الدول
الداخليه واحترام روح واستراليا الذي رفض
هذا الامر ليست روسيا الذي رفض هذا الامر
الامريكيين ونصبوا فخل بوتين كي يدخل الى
اوكرانيا
بس بس دقيقه
لم يقع بالفخ خلينا ناخذ
من العرب الذين يراهنون على نظام دولي
جديد متعدد الاقطاب وتقول انهم سينتقلون
فقط من يد الامريكي اذا كانوا في يد
الامريكي الى ايدي الصين والروسي البعض
يقول لك على الاقل انهم يستطيعون الان
اللعب على صراعات الكبار ماذا استفدنا من
النظام العالمي يعني واحد يقول لك واحد
العرب الان يا اخي بسخريه ينتقلون من
التخت الغربي الى التخت الشرقي يعني التخت
الشرقي طبعا الموسيقى مشان ما حدا يفهمنا
غلط كيف ترد
يعني اول حاجه يعني امريكا بعد اجتماعات
بوتين مع شريف خمسه فبراير 2022 فائد بقى
فائد بتعمل اجراءات قويه
لتاخير انهيار النظام الدولي فانا ببشر
صديقك في بيروت واقول له حتى انهيار
النظام الدولي سياخذ سنواتا طويلا لان
تحالفات ضخمه اقليميه قامت بها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وكوس وكواد والعيون
الخمسه
القمه الامريكيه الافريقيه
وتوسيع الناتو اكبر حلف عسكري في التاريخ
32 دوله
والاتحاد والاشتراكي عبر الاطلسي ومجموعه
العشرين ومجموعه 7 معنى هذا ان هناك بدائل
كبيره جدا تؤخر انهيار النظام الدولي
لسنوات فانا ابشر صديقك اللي مبسوط بان
نظام الدولي والفوضى والهيمنه والغزوه
وعوده الامبرياليه والكلام ده ان ده كمان
هياخذ وقت كبير قوي ثانيا قبل ان يهدم
نظام دولي
النظام دولي جديد هياخد له 30 40 سنه
سيكون عصر البترول قد انتهى وستكون الشرق
الاوسط نفسه منطقه هامشيه لكل العالم هو
الشرق الاوسط في ايه الا البترول بعد
البترول ما لوش لازمه انا انا بقول لك بعد
البترول ستصبح هذه المنطقه مهمله فحتى
رهنهم على نظام دولي جديد سيكونون خارج
التاريخ وقتها ارد على صاحب صديقك برده في
الاستوديو في بيروت انا بقول لك انتم
رهنتوا على الاتحاد السوفيتي وفشلته
وروسيا اسوا من الاتحاد السوفيتي الاجنده
التي يقدمها بوتين الهوس بالتاريخ والهوس
بالامبرياليه والهوس توسيع توسيع روسيا
مره اخرى كما حدث تاريخيا هذا اخطر كمان
من الاتحاد السوفيتي بتقول ان روسيا قدمت
نظام لامريكا نظام انت انت بتكلم مين انا
انا قرات المذكره ونشرت المذكره التي
ارسلها بوتين سنه 24 ديسم 2021 ومن ضمن
بنود المذكره اللي طالبها بوتين ان ما
يبقاش في تعاون نهائي عسكري ما بين حلف
الاطلاق الناتو وما بين دول الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق يعني عاوز يفكك حلف
الناتو عاوز يفكك حلف الناتو مش نظام
عالمي جديد قائم على العدل كما تقول هو ما
يعرفش العدل اساسا لو كان يعرف العدل
لنشره في بلده لو كان يعرف العدل
معارضيه بالسم لو كان يعرف العدل ما كانش
التجا الى مرتزقه ومجرمين يبعتهم اوكرانيا
ويبعتهم سوريا ويبعتهم ليبيا هو ما يعرفش
هذا ما يعرفش اصلا العدل ولا الديمقراطيه
ولا نظام دولي ولا حقوق انسان لا يعرف هذا
بتتكلم على ده بوتين بيتكلم على امريكا
والعسكره ده هو اللي اطلق سلاح نووي كم
مره بوتن
وحلفائه في النظام هددوا العالم بالاسلحه
النوويه بوتين اطلق
سباقا نوويا خطيرا في العالم وبعد مع
نهايه هذا العقل سينضم الى النادي النووي
عده دول جديده نتيجه ما طرحه بوتين من ان
النووي هو الحل النووي هو الحمايه ولو
للنووي الروسي لفشله روسيا
اجتاح حلف الاطلسي روسيا في في عده ايام
عده ايام يعني ده جيشه منهار هو جيشه
بيلعب تكنيكات القرن الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
ولسه لسه بيستخدم تكتيكات الحرب العالميه
الثانيه فبالتالي هذه مغالطات كثيره
تراهنوا على بتقول لك احنا حاربنا اسرائيل
بسلاح السوفيات ما فشلته يا سيدي انتوا
نجحتوا بسلاح السوفيتنا فين اسرائيل وفين
انتم فين اسرائيل كل حياتها فشل
والاشتراقيين كله نسيت حرب تشرين
التحريريه يا زلمه
يا فشلوا في التنميه فشلوا في الديمقراطيه
فشلوا في احترام حقوق الانسان فشلوا في
الكرامه الانسانيه لشعبهم فشلوا في كل شيء
عندما رهنوا على الاتحاد السوفيتي فشلوا
في كل شيء ويعيدون الرهانات الخاطئه على
الصين وعلى روسيا من اجل حقبه اخرى من
الفشل عقودا اخرى من الفشل اللي عمله عبد
الناصر في ويوليو اخواتها السبعه التمن
دول دي 100 سنه دلوقتي متخرجه وهتقعد
خمسين سنه متخرجه تاني ده لو اتصلحت اساسا
يعني انت بعد 100 سنه من التخريب نتيجه
التعاون مع السوفيات ست عاوز تحط المنطقه
العربيه في مئه سنه من الفشل والخراب
والانهيار مع الصين وروسيا جميل جدا هذا
التفكير عقلاني يا سلام يا سلام سؤال وجيه
سؤال خليني اخده منك مجدي خليني اخذ منك
السؤال هذا دكتور كلام مجدي هذا ياخذنا
الى يعني انتم لماذا تراهنون على روسيا يا
روسيا الان لم تصبح
قطبا مؤثرا وفاعلا في النظام الدولي
الجديد لم تصبح بعد يعني لم تصبح 5% من
الاتحاد السوفيتي لننظر ماذا تقدمه لنا
روسيا في سوريا جاءت الى سوريا
جربت اكثر من 300 سلاح فتاك فوق رؤوس
السوريين بشهاده وزير الدفاع الروسي نهبت
معظم ثروات روسيا سوريا وضعت يدها على كل
الموانع وضعت يدها على الفوسفات وضعت يدها
على الغاز وضعت يدها على منابع النفط
الجديده مش عم نحكي عن شرق الفرات اخذت كل
شيء في سوريا جاءت الى سوريا للنهب والسلب
روسيا واتحدى اتحدى ماذا قدمت سوريا روسيا
للسوريين السوريين يموتون من الجوع لا
يجدون الخبز لا يجدون البنزين لا يجدون
كذا وانت تعلم روسيا اكبر من اكبر مصدري
الغاز والنفط في العالم كم برميل نف ط
صدرت الى سوريا نون كم الريف خبز صدرت الى
سوريا هذه روسيا هذه بلد نهب وسلب لا
علاقه لها على شو عم بتراهنوا ما هذه
روسيا اجت على سوريا ماذا قدمت لنا
السوريون يموتون من الجوع في قلب اللاذقيه
ماذا قدمت لنا على شو عم ترانو يا زلمه شو
رايحين على روسيا هدول هدول هدول شحادين
ومنور هدول كيف ترد
يعني كمان بدك تسمح لي بسمحلك مشان
لانه بهمني انا المشاهد يعرف ما هي
المتحولات التي حدثت الاستاذ الدكتور مجدي
عم يحكي عن وضع روسيا المنهار وكذا وكذا
وكذا انا لدي تقرير من البنك الدولي
بقول ان الاقتصاد الروسي يعني هذه الدوله
يلي بيعتبرها دوله ديكتاتوريه بيعتبر ان
الاقتصاد الروسي سيتذوق على الجميع في
ستزيد نسبه النمو في روسيا
2.1% في منطقه اليورو ستتراجع بالاضافه
الى التراجع واحد فاصل سته بالميه في كندا
واحد فاصله خمسه بالمئه في المانيا واحد
فاصله اربعه بالمئه في امريكا واحد بالميه
كمان تراجع في بريطانيا 0.9 وفي اليابان
0.9 روسيا اكيد وفق منظور البنك الدولي
روسيا يا صديقي العزيز تتفوق على الجميع
وتوقعات البنك الدولي بينمنوه نمو
الاقتصاد الروسي بوطيره اعلى من امريكا
واوروبا واليابان
وكندا
يا دكتور رياض الوقت يداهم بس يا دكتور
رياض يا دكتور رياض انت على من تراهن هل
تعلم هل تعلم يا دكتور رياض ان البنوك
الروسيه هل تعلم الخليجيين اللي بده
يتعاملوا مع روسيا يا سيدي الروس الان
روسيا لا تستطيع ان ترسل دولار واحد الى
اي مكان في العالم روسيا محاصره يا رجل
لماذا انتم لماذا تراهنون على الاحصنه
لمكرسحه روسيا لا تستطيع ان تصدر شيء
محاصره حصارا كاملا حتى الى سوريا الى
سوريا ذات يوم ارادوا طلبوا السوريين قروض
من روسيا تعرف شو قالوا ان البنك الروسي
قال لهم علينا عقوبات امريكيه منخاف من
العقوبات الامريكيه يا رجل بتشده على على
حمير متخطخه كيف ترد
اليوم اليوم قبل ايضا ان اريد ان اعطي
ايضا نموذج عن الاقتصاد الامريكي برجع
اختصار باختصار الاقتصاد الامريكي نعم
الاقتصاد الامريكي في عهد جو بايدن
8.5% التضخم هو اعلى مستوى في امريكا منذ
40 عام الان وصل تضخم لفوق 12%
0.4 وصلت للخمسه بالميه الفائده التي هي
اعلى منذ 14 عام في امريكا البطاله وصلت
للخمسه بالميه هي اعلى منذ 50 عام في
امريكا الاسهم الامريكيه نزلت
0.7% وهذا في عهد بايدن وهذا لم يحدث في
امريكا منذ عشرات باخت اذا اختصار
باختصار باختصار اما نعم يعني تفضل اما
بالنسبه انا عايز قول ان روسيا التي
يعتبرها الاستاذ مجدي انها دوله
الامبراطوريه حاليا هناك تقدم في الاقتصاد
الروسي نسبه بوتين شعبيته تفاقدت 80%
وبالتالي الاقتصاد الروسي مستقر
وحتى الان الكلف التي تكلفتها روسيا في
حرب اوكرانيا تساوي 10%
بينما الاقتصاد الاوروبي يا ان الاقتصاد
الامريكي يائن ووضع امريكي واوروبا
هذا الكلام مهم مجدي ما يقوله الدكتور
بس خليني اخذه لانه الوقت انتهى دكتور
رياض خليني اخذ كلامك مجدي طيب هذا الكلام
مؤكد يؤكد ما يحدث الان في العالم وفي
منطقه الشرق الاوسط بشكل خاص ماذا تقرا في
هذا التمرد العربي على الهيمنه والجبروت
الامريكي مجدي خليل الا تعتقد ان هذا يعني
هذا التمرد العربي الان هناك تمرد هناك
تمرد يذهبون باتجاه الصين يذهبون باتجاه
روسيا ينوعون تحالفاتهم ومن حقهم العرب
الا تعتقد ان هذا اكبر مؤشر على ان امريكا
بدات تسقط وان هناك نظاما متعدد الاقطاب
بدا يظهر الى الوجود كيف ترد
يعني انا كما قلت لك ان نظام متعدد
الاقطاب دعاوز له عشرات السنين زي ما اذا
قلنا ان احنا دلوقتي قدامنا اذا اذا
اتكلمنا عن اقطار ما فيش اقطاب اساسا اذا
اتكلمنا عن اقطاب هنقول قطب ونصف يعني
الصين وروسيا وكوريا الشماليه
وفنزويلا مثلا وايران مثلا في مقابل ايه
في مقابل الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه واستراليا وكندا ازاي تقارن هذا
بذاكه يعني ازاي تقارن يعني حتى تريد ان
تقول من الذي يقف تريد ان تسال الى
الدكتور رياض من الذي يقف مع روسيا والصين
الان غير ايران وكوريا الشماليه قالوا
سوريا تصور قال سوريا بصراحه بشار هو اللي
راح يقلب الموازين كيف ترد
خليني اكمل بس خليني اكمل اتكلم عن
الاقتصاد الامريكي تقريبا في اخر في اخر
ثلاث عقود مستقر ربع اقتصاد العالم بيدور
حوالين ربع اقتصاد العالم في ثلاث عقود ما
تغيرش تقريبا في الثلاث عقود اللي بيتكلم
على روسيا روسيا عندها اكبر دوله في
العالم 17 مليون كيلومتر مربع وسكانها 140
مليون يعني عندها اكل تقدر تعيش بالاكل
عندها طاقه وغاز تقدر تبيع وتعيش لكن انا
بتكلم على التقدم الاقتصادي عن قدمه ايه
للعالم عندها ايه روسيا محاصره بيقول لك
هو مش عارفه الروبل ايه هو ما فيش اساسا
ما تقدرش تشتري دولار في روسيا اساسا ده
كله فيك كل ما يصدر هما متخصصين من ايام
الاتحاد السوفيتي في اجنده
الزيف والبروباندا شاطرين في البروبان هم
بيعانوا معاناه معاناه رهيبه ومحاصرين
ومحاصرين بيشتروا من ايران اسلحه وبيشتروا
من كوريا الشماليه ذخيره مش قادرين
يحاربوا بيقول لك ان انا من سبع شهور مش
قادرين
يحتلوا بلد صغيره
سبع شهور دلوقتي اتقتل فيها اكتر من 40
الف روسي عشان يحتلوا دوله اصلا عدد مدينه
عدد سكانها 70 الف بتقول لي ان روسيا
روسيا ايه روسيا محاصره اقتصاديا
واقتصادها في انهيار جميل واسيبك من النوم
ما يعيش وياك صدام حسين تحت الحصار كان
شعبه عايش وبياكل القذافي تحت الحصان كان
شعبه عايش وبياكل ايران تحت الحصار شعبها
عايشه بياكل هم بيتصوروا عدم سقوط النظام
هو انتصار ايران مثلا كانت من ثلاث سنين
الريال بتاعها ب 5 الدولار 45,000 ريال
دلوقتي 530 الف ريال
دقيقه مجدي باختصار مجدي باختصار بجمله
واحده
بجمله واحده
ماذا
تقرب المندفعين باتجاه روسيا والصين
والتحالفات الجديده بجمله واحده
ارى هانكم خاسر واللي بيكلمكم على انكم
تبقى قوه عظمى ده هذا كلام وهم منافقين
بيكتبوا لكم يقولوا لكم السعوديه العظمى
والدول العظمى والكلام ده هذا كلام وهم
عندما يتشكل نظام عالمي جديد بعد عقود
ستكونون خارج التاريخ لان البترول الوحيد
اللي انتم تملكه هيكون سلعه انتهى عهدها
وبالتالي ما ترهنوش خليكم مع اللي ساعدتكم
في التنميه سعادتكم في الازدهار اللي
بنتلكم دوالكم في الخليج دوالكم الخليج دي
صناعه غربيه دول الخليج بالكامل صناعه
غربيه اما الصناعه السوفيتيه الشرقيه فهي
الدول الخربانه في الشرق جميل جدا وصلت
الفكره دكتور رياض ماذا تقول للعالم
وللعرب الذين يذهبون ويقتنصون فرصه العالم
النظام الدولي الجديد باختصار
باختصار بالجملتين ثلاثه اقول ان مصلحه
اقول ان مصلحه العالم العربي في هذا
الاتجاه الذي بداه محمد بن سلمان باتجاه
الشرق مصلحه العالم العربي ان تنهي
الصراعات المذهبيه لتتحول المنطقه الى
واحه من الاستثمار مصلحه العالم العربي ان
تدخل في عصر التنميه جديده لان الصين هي
اكبر الدول تنميه في العالم
من اصل 30 براءه اختراع سجلوا العام
الماضي عشرين براءه اختراع شجلتها الصين
الصين متقدمه على امريكا اقتصاديا متقدما
تكنولوجيا متقدما بالذكاء الصناعي
في كل شيء اذا العرب مصلحتهم مع الصين
جميل جدا مجدي خليل الكلمه الاخيره لك
لانه بدات معه بجمله واحده مجدي خليل كيف
ترد على هذا الكلام وبجمله واحده وخلص
خاسر اذا رهن على الاستبداد والديكتاتوريه
والامبرياليه ستطولهم الامبرياليه سيطولهم
الاستعمار وستستعمر بلادهم
ستستعمر اذا رهنت على الامبرياليه وعلى
عوده الفوضى الدوليه وعوده قانون الغابه
وعوده القوه كمؤشر اساسي فقط في العالم
وعوده الهوس بالتاريخ الصين لانكم انتم
الصين انقذت 500 مليون صيني من حق الخط
الفقر هاي في الفتره الماضيه امبرياليه
صعل عم تحكي عنها انقذت 550 مليون صيني من
حافه الفقر الى المستوى المتوسط
هم يقررون نفس الكلام كانوا يقولون نفس
الكلام عن الاتحاد السوفيتي ويكررون على
السنا هم حبيبي هم عقله عقل مبرمج على
الانبهار بالفشل اشكرك جزيل الشكر على
الانبهار بالفشل اشكرك جزيل الشكر
مشاهدينا الكرام لم يبقى لنا لا نشكر
ضيفينا من واشنطن مجدي خليل ومن بيروت
الرياض عيد
نلتقي مساء ثلاث المقبل فحتى ذلك الحين هو
فيصل القاسم يحييكم من الدوحه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]